glauben sie gold ist geld
nein es ist ein edelmetall obwohl es
6000 jahre lang geld war bis jemand
dieses ökonomische gesetz auf den kopf
stellte naja es ist kapital
[Musik]
der irrtum über gold ist dass es
spekulativ wäre der größte irrtum ist
dass gold finanz panik und die große
depression ausgelöst hätte das stimmt
nicht
gold wird immer mit aktien verglichen
die meisten verstehen einfach nichts von
heute der größte irrtum über gold ist
dass es nicht länger geld sei dass ein
präsident 1971 feststellt die gold wäre
nicht länger geld und das zur tatsache
erklärte nach 4000 jahren kontrollierten
bürokraten das geld das ist für jeden
der geschichte und wirtschaft kennt
einfach absurd
[Musik]
gold polarisiert wie kein anderer
finanzwert für viele ist es das einzig
wahre geld ob man daran glaubt oder
nicht gold hat jahrtausendelang alle
anderen währungen überlebt
[Musik]
ich bin grant berlioz und in dieser
serie werde ich ergründen wie gold zu
geld wurde welche schritte für die
gewinnung einer unze gold erforderlich
sind und welche stellung gold in der
modernen finanzwelt hat wir beleuchten
die geschichte des goldstandards wie
gold weltweit gehandelt wird und welche
erstaunlichen maßnahmen für seinen
schutz ergriffen werden
letztendlich wollen wir ergründen warum
dieses außergewöhnliche gelbe metall die
menschheit seit jahrtausenden derart
fasziniert
[Musik]
die stellung des goldes als währung seit
es vor jahrtausenden entdeckt wurde ist
tief in unserer gesellschaft verankert
aber wie und warum wurde dieses gelbe
metall dreh und angelpunkt unserer
finanzwelt gold es seit jahrtausenden
geld umso faszinierender ist das bis vor
etwa 100 jahren niemand wusste warum
es war für alle so es war
marktwirtschaftliches gut aber niemand
benutzt es der könig von judäa sagte
nicht benutzen wir das gold es war teil
des marktes
laut dem milliardär eric sprott ist die
geschichte der welt die geschichte des
goldes seine einzigartige beständigkeit
und seltenheit machte gold seit jeher
wertvoll als geschmolzenes eisen den
erdkern formte so ist das meiste gold
des planeten mit sich mit dem gold im
erdkern könnte man die gesamte
erdoberfläche einen halben meter dick
vergolden wenn man es abbauen könnte
für die frühesten kulturen war goldwert
speicher tausch gegenstand und zierte
die ägypter sahen im gold die sonne ihre
götter herrsche und ewiges leben
die inkas beschrieben gold als tränen
der sonne für humor war gold in der
ilias und der odyssey wohlstand für
menschen und rom für die unsterblichen
edelmetalle wurden zuerst circa 700 vor
christus in form von münzen als geld
verwendet die händler in libyen aus
einer natürlichen legierung aus gold und
silber namens elektrum treten dank der
eigenschaften des goldes konnten die
templer im dreizehnten jahrhundert die
ersten banken in europa schaffen
man zahlte sein gold ein und konnte auf
reisen auf dem ganzen kontinent einen
gegenwert abheben
da sein wert als währung überall erkannt
wurde ermöglichte gold eine florierende
wirtschaft über grenzen und kulturen
hinweg
es half bei der entdeckung und
besiedlung neuer welten und ermöglichte
weltweiten handelsnetz heute jedoch sind
wir in der ersten ära der
menschheitsgeschichte in der keine
landeswährung mehr auf gold passiert
warum also ist gold in der finanzwelt
noch immer so wichtig obwohl es nicht
länger geld ist ich würde sagen gold es
zunächst immer noch geld eine der vielen
formen ein austausch medium und
wertspeicher nicht wie andere währungen
wie fiat geld und crypto währungen vor
diesem hintergrund werden auf dem
goldmarkt täglich milliarden
umgeschlagen zu sagen es wäre kein geld
ist demnach ein irrtum
es gab eine zeit da war gold in vielen
gesellschaften das einzige geld und das
war einmal
gold ist eine von vielen währungen es
ist direkte zahlung und nicht
zahlungsversprechen das meiste geld ist
nur ein zahlungsversprechen nicht die
zahlung an sich gold ist sehr wichtig
denn es hat als einziges geld der
menschheitsgeschichte bis heute überlebt
über jahrhunderte auch vor 2000 jahren
schon zerstörten regierungen stets den
wert von fiat geld oder papiergeld oder
silbermünzen in der römerzeit
so weit dass es wertlos wurde
gold ist heute wichtig da es wird
speichert aktuell haben wir einen großen
mangel an verlässlichen wert speichern
man überlege einmal was gold ist das
andere finanzwerte nicht sind es ist
selten unabhängig niemandes selbst
verpflichtung oder haftung
es wird auf niemanden ausgestellt und
ist ohne im prima tour und zeugnis gut
und gültig es wird nicht abgelehnt es
ist was es ist
es ist greifbar in unserer finanzierten
verbrieften welt in der alles selbst
grundbesitz in form von wertpapieren
gehandelt wird die bloße
zahlungsverpflichtungen sind obliegt die
vermittlung von ansprüchen
vielschichtigen finanzinstitutionen aber
auch die stoßen manchmal an ihre grenzen
das gute an gold ist dass man es nicht
einfach mit der druckerpresse
vervielfältigen kann man kann nicht mehr
trocken oder einfach ein paar nullen an
den kontostand anhängen ist man kann
nicht mehr drucken darum ist es das
bessere geld wenn es nicht geld ist
warum haben die usa 8000 tonnen davon
warum hat der iwf 3000 tonnen
warum hat russland seine goldreserven in
den letzten zehn jahren verdreifacht
warum kauft china jedes fitzelchen gold
obwohl sie das meiste abbauen und nichts
davon exportieren
gold ist also aus denselben gründen geld
wie in vorangegangenen jahrhunderten
obwohl viele dieser gründe religiöser
natur sind ist der glaube an einen
zeitlosen physischen wert der sich seit
anbeginn der zivilisationen behauptet
vielleicht weniger verwunderlich als der
glaube der präsidentin heutiger
zentralbanken an ihr finanzsystem das
aus dem nichts millionenwerte in fiat
währung erschaffen kann
warum aber wurden ausgerechnet die
elemente gold und silber zu geld um das
zu beantworten brauchen wir im
periodensystem und einen dicken roten
stift
streichen wir zunächst einmal alle gase
dinge wie wasserstoff oder aragon können
wir schließlich nicht als geld verwenden
dann entfernen wir elemente wie kalzium
und natrium die sich in wasser auflösen
und alles das mit luft reagiert ob es
nun zerfällt oder feuer fängt so etwas
will man nicht in seiner tasche haben
somit fallen 56 elemente weg
[Musik]
dann entfernen wir natürlich noch alles
radioaktive man will ja nicht von seinem
geld getötet werden
dadurch fallen erstaunliche 45 elemente
weg wer aufgepasst hat weiß dass noch
fünf sogenannte edelmetalle übrig sind
gold silber rhodium platin und palladium
rhodium und palladium waren bis ins 18
jahrhundert unbekannt sie scheinen also
aus das problem an platin ist der
schmelzpunkt von etwa 1800 grad celsius
was früher schmelzöfen bei weitem nicht
bewältigen konnten
bleiben nur noch gold und silber es
waren diese beiden edlen metalle die die
menschheit als wertspeicher und tausch
medien verwenden würde
obwohl gold nicht mehr als währung dient
ist sein nutzen als wertspeicher
ungebrochen wenn man jedoch
wertgegenstände verwahrt muss man sie
damit auch schützen
viele halten die lagerung von gold 4
umständlich und teuer
stimmt nur bedingt wie kauft man also
gold und wenn man es hat wo lagert man
es am sichersten gold muss abseits der
institutionen gelagert werden gegen die
es als absicherung dient oder gegen
deren probleme oder zusammenbruches als
sicherheitsdienst und selbstverständlich
sollte man es so lagern dass man selbst
darauf zugreifen kann
viele lagern ihr gold wie auch ich in
sichere verwahrung
sie ziehen es vor es außerhalb des
rechts bereiches ihres staates zu lagern
da es ihnen auch als versicherung gegen
die übergriffe ihrer eigenen regierung
dienen soll
kabel mit solange es greifbar zugeteilt
und separiert ist ist es egal es kommt
dann auf die qualität des instituts und
seine sicherheitsvorkehrungen an
man kann natürlich ohne weiteres eine
halbe million euro in goldbarren in
einem safe verwahren
aber es gibt orte an denen das vermögen
ganz erstarrten lagert und geheime
tresore in denen die reichsten menschen
der welt ihren reichtum für ihre
nachkommen lagern
eine solche schatzkammer liegt in den
schweizer alpen
sie enthält privates gold im wert von
milliarden und wurde noch nie zuvor
gefällt uns wurde es jedoch gestattet
diesen geheimsten ort der welt anzusehen
und zu zeigen was die menschen auf sich
nehmen um ihre edelmetalle zu schützen
wir sind hier im größten privaten gold
tresor der welt hier lagert das gold
reicher familien institutionen
privatbanken und sogar einiger
zentralbanken auf dem weg durch das
gewölbe gibt es eine reihe
sicherheitsbereiche wir sind hier tief
im berg wir sind kilometerweit durch
verschiedene sicherheitsbereiche und
stockwerke tief in den schweizer berg
eingedrungen um den ort zu erreichen an
dem das gold tatsächlich liegt
es ist der einzige tresor seiner art der
vor atom schlägen erdbeben und gas
angriffen geschützt ist
so viel sicherheit gibt es sonst
nirgends
ich weiß nicht durch wie viele türen
nicht gegangen oder wie weit wir
gegangen sind
ich bin hier mitten in einem berg
irgendwo in der schweiz erst an einem
ort wie diesem begreift man was menschen
auf sich nehmen um dieses gelbe metall
zu verwahren
die nötigen sicherheitsmaßnahmen
ergriffen werden müssen um es zu
schützen
die idee die kaufkraft zu verwahren ist
der hauptgrund für den goldkauf als
wertspeicher eine strategie die sich
seit menschengedenken bewährt hunderte
währungen wurden im laufe der geschichte
entwertet gold blieb jedoch stets der
ankerpunkt das herz des finanzsystems
grund dafür sind die eigenschaften die
es ursprünglich zu geld machten
gold ist haltbar transportabel vom
giebel und heilbar
dank dieser kombination an eigenschaften
hat es alle alternativen fiat währungen
der letzten 6000 jahre überlebt bogens
sorgt pleiten krieg und hungersnot und
auch die städte fähigkeit des menschen
fiat währungen zu entwerten
der dollar war zwar die leitwährung der
letzten 40 jahre
doch das war nicht immer so das
britische pfund die spanische peseta
selbst der portugiesische esco sie alle
hatten einst die gleiche stellung inne
wie der dollar heute wann immer eine
zivilisation expandieren wollte waren
die bemühungen stets durch ihre
goldreserven begrenzt die
immer beschnitten ihre münzen
verringerten dadurch ihren gold und
silber wert und somit die löhne ihrer
armeen bis sich die soldaten weigerten
zu kämpfen
den großteil der letzten 200 jahre
folgte die welt eine art goldstandard
nun leben wir jedoch in der ersten ihrer
der geschichte in der allein fiat
währungen herrschen ihr regime begann
1971 als richard nixon den dollar vom
gold entkoppelte
weil heute die verbindung mit dem gold
fehlt konnten regierungen
unverantwortbare schulden anhäufen
können gesellschaften diesen stetig
wachsenden schuldenberg nicht mehr
bewältigen ist eine rückkehr zum
goldstandard nahezu sicher unser system
basiert rein auf fiat geld seit richard
nixon den umtausch des dollars in gold
aussetzte angeblich nur zeitweise
daher erscheint die rückkehr zu einem
goldstandard unvorstellbar und unmöglich
dem goldstandard wird die
weltwirtschaftskrise angelastet und
bekannte politiker und ökonomen
behaupten eine rückkehr zum goldstandard
sei heute unmöglich
die frage ist warum was war der gold
standard warum erregt die idee ihn
wieder zu etablieren so sehr die gemüter
in regierungen und zentralbanken von
1836 bis 1913 gab es keine
us-zentralbank das war eine der grössten
wohlstands epochen der weltgeschichte
nicht nur in amerika erfindungen wie
telefon erntemaschinen das flugzeug
radio der fotograf gewaltige zuwächse
bei elektrifizierung und produktivität
industrielle erfolgsgeschichte nennt
lokalen amerikas wachstum ohne
zentralbank war gewaltig zuallererst war
es freiwillig jedes land konnte
entscheiden ob es mit machen wollte für
viele sheen ist die richtige idee
man muss die nur für sich entscheiden
okay wir drucken papiergeld aber es
lässt sich zu einem festen kurs in gold
tauschen
so legte man es also fest das war die
regel daran hielten sich da nun also
eine reihe währungen zu festen kursen in
gold tausch waren konnte man sie auch zu
einem festen kurs gegeneinander tauschen
so funktionierte die welt ganz ohne die
führung von bürokraten
wer ein handelsdefizit hatte musste
dafür mit gold bezahlen was passierte
also wenn man so gold abgeben musste und
sein geldvolumen verringerte deflation
preise sanken löhne oft natürlich auch
aber so würde man konkurrenzfähiger und
durch die gesteigerte nachfrage
erwirtschaftete man wieder einen handel
was geschah also wenn man durch diesen
überschuss gold bekam das geldvolumen
stieg inflation preise stiegen mann
wurde weniger konkurrenzfähig
das system balanciert sich selbst der
goldstandard war eine methode sowohl
politische eliten als auch wähler zu
zwingen sich an die realität zu halten
zumindest im bezug auf das
wirtschaftssystem das nicht auf reine
mathematik basierte es kam mehrfach vor
dass der goldstandard scheiterte jedoch
nie wegen des systems an sich nie wegen
des goldes es waren stets politiker die
sich nicht an den goldstandard hielten
der goldstandard funktionierte nicht
weil die geldausgaben nicht die
ausbeuten konnten die sparten politiker
waren hier natürlich schlüsselfiguren
heute würde es nicht funktionieren weil
die politischen eliten kein system
wollen dass ihre macht beschränkt in den
1950 erschien in der new york times ein
leitartikel macht ihm der goldstandard
nicht gescheitert sondern ermordet
worden wäre getötet von den alliierten
damit sie ihre kriege führen könnten
vor dem ersten weltkrieg nahm an
allgemein an der krieg könnte nur ein
paar monate dauern da die regierungen
nicht genug geld hätten um sich einen
derartigen viel leisten zu können
dabei wurde vernachlässigt dass
regierungen einfach die ein tausch
barkeit aufheben und mehr geld drucken
würden um krieg zu führen
bei dem treffen in kemptal wird am 15
august 1971 waren fünf leute zugegen
richard nixon kam mit seinem
wirtschaftsteam da camp david walker
damals stellvertretender finanzminister
verbandsvorsitzender der john connally
der finanzminister präsident nixon und
ein fünfter jahrelang konnte ich nicht
herausfinden wer der fünfte war es war
ein freund von mir
kenneth dem ehemals dekan der
juristischen fakultät der universität
von chicago
ich sprach mit worker und kfd also mit
zwei der fünf hauptbeteiligten der
entscheidung und beide sagten mir sie
dachten wirklich es wäre nur
vorübergehend
ein seit jahrtausenden bewährtes
geldsystem fällt der unterschrift eines
präsidenten zum opfer doch was änderte
sich als nächsten den dollar von seinem
goldenen anker löste wie beeinflusste
dass unser heutiges konzept von geld die
welt veränderte sich gewaltig als nixon
das gold fenster schloss bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt quasi in unmittelbarer folge
des zweiten weltkriegs gab es das
bretton woods system in dem der dollar
mit einem tausch wert von 35 dollar pro
unze an gold gebunden war
alle anderen währungen waren an den
dollar gebunden
dadurch erlangte der dollar im neuen
system quasi den gleichen stellenwert
wie gold sie schlossen das gold fenster
und waren sich sicher es morgen wieder
zu öffnen
[Musik]
für den fall dass es eine flucht aus dem
dollar gelbe oder das vertrauen in das
geldsystem verloren ginge wählt man sich
bereit das fenster nahezu sofort wieder
zu öffnen
es war also eigentlich nur ein
testballon versuchen wir es einmal so
weil uns das geld ausgegangen ist und
wir ansonsten viel genauer wirtschaften
bis an das fenster zu schliessen
veränderte an sich also erst mal gar
nichts
entscheidend war dass alle anderen
mitmachten hätten alle gesagt wie bitte
dollar als reines papiergeld auf keinen
fall nein wäre der dollar eingebrochen
und die schatzwechsel nicht mehr
angenommen werden
denn dann hätten wir immer noch den
goldstandard die gleichgültigkeit der
bevölkerung erlaubt er es nixon mit
dieser änderung davonzukommen
wenn man an 1971 zurück denkt und sich
fragt ob weltweit mehr menschen nixon
vertrauten oder dem gold muss man
bedenken dass der goldpreis von 35
dollar auf 850 dollar stieg das sagt
einem einiges über den stellenwert von
nixon und den des goldes dem gold ist
nichts passiert doch was dem dollar in
den folgenden 40 jahren widerfuhr war
katastrophal
die ganze finanzierung des systems war
resultat des sanften zahlungsverzugs der
us notenbanken von 1971 sanfter
zahlungsverzug daher dass die tausch
barcode des goldes nur zeitweise
ausgesetzt war sie das gold also immer
noch schuldig waren einfach gesagt als
nixon im august 1971 den goldstandard
abschaffte wie man sagte geriet die idee
gold wäre geld ins wanken da der dollar
nicht mehr daran gebunden war
manche glaubten gold würde einbrechen
ohne nachfrage als währung verschwinden
das war sinn denn der dollar war
aufgrund seiner verbindung zum gold so
stabil nicht umgekehrt
nachdem wir erfahren haben wie und warum
gold zu geld wurde und sich
jahrhundertelang gegenüber allen fiat
währungen als weit überlegener
wertspeicher erwies
befassen wir uns mit der suche des
menschen nach gold und den bemühungen es
an immer schwierigeren orten abzubauen
und in schmuck waren und die uns so
vertrauten münzen zu verwandeln
milton friedman sagte einst was warren
buffett gerne zitiert dass der goldabbau
verrückt zeigt man baut gold in einem
erdteil abtransportiert es fort und
vergräbt es anderswo in einem anderen
loch ein marsianer würde bei dem anblick
wohl den kopf schütteln es ist natürlich
etwas befremdlich etwas für verrückt zu
erklären dass menschen seit 4000 bis
10.000 jahren tun scheint weit hergeholt
verrückte dinge tun wir menschen in
kurzen zügen nicht sie in tausend jahre
lang
gold ist eines der seltensten elemente
19 mal schwerer als wasser und fast
doppelt so schwer wie blei
doch es macht nur drei milliardstel der
erdkruste aus umso größer ist die
herausforderung dieses kostbare metall
zu finden
seit beginn der zivilisation wurden der
menschheit immer größere mühen
aufgezwungen um das gold der erdkruste
abzubauen
sehen wir uns nun die evolution des
goldabbaus der letzten tausend jahre an
das höchste gold kam aus flüssen die für
den abbau umgeleitet wurden um das gold
freizulegen
im antiken griechenland galt gold als
verbindung von wasser und sonnenlicht da
es in flüssen gefunden worden
beim goldwaschen schwenkt man wasser mit
sedimenten des flusses in metall warnen
um das gold heraus zu waschen
[Musik]
1200 vor christus filterten findige
goldschürfer goldhaltigen sand mit
wasserdruck durch dichtes schaaf l wobei
sich die schweren goldpartikel verfingen
war es voll gesogen konnte das goldene
vlies zum trocknen aufgehängt und das
gold heraus geklopft werden
daher kommt auch die legende vom
goldenen vlies
einige frühe zivilisationen nutzten eine
ähnliche methode namens we know how bei
der die erde auf volt tüchern geschüttet
wurde wobei der wind den leichteren
sandweg blies und das gold freilegte
[Musik]
nachdem das gold an der oberfläche
abgebaut war mussten goldsucher tief
schürfen darin methoden ersinnen
sie gingen nach unten in die erdkruste
wo sie in größeren gruppen arbeiten
mussten
der abbau unter tage reicht bis in die
römerzeit zurück
die wahre herausforderung jedoch bestand
darin die primitiven methoden aufzugeben
und immer komplexere maschinen zu
entwickeln um das gold aus dem harten
fels unter der erdoberfläche abzubauen
der anfängliche abbau von quarz gestein
oberflächennahe vorkommen war relativ
simpel doch bis in die 1800 60er jahre
reichte der abbau nicht einmal 100 meter
tief
aufgrund der enormen geologischen und
wirtschaftlichen herausforderungen des
früheren bergbaus brauchte der
technologische fortschritt viele jahre
bis tiefer erz erreichbar wurde
antrieb stollen in den harten fels und
das gold aus den quartz gestein zu lösen
man wurde von hand mit pressluft poren
oder auch mit ein wenig dynamit
hydraulische bohrer waren die nächste
entwicklung
sie konnten tiefere löcher in die erde
bohren mit bor köpfen die mit steigender
tiefe immer länger und dünner wurden die
großen ausgegrabenen felsen wurden von
schweren eisernen stampfen zermalmt um
das gold herauszulösen
die hydro mechanische gewinnung nutzte
wasserstrahlen mit hohem druck um stein
und erde abzutragen und das gold
freizulegen hoch in den bergen wurde
wasser umgeleitet und in rohren
gebündelt auf dem weg nach unten stieg
der druck durch die schwerkraft wo das
wasser mit über 340 bar durch eine
kleine düse geleitet wurde und so selbst
berge auf sprengte das weggewaschen
erdreich strömte talwärts und wurde in
vielen abgeschieden
die neue fördermethode war ertragreich
hatte jedoch einen preis das umgeleitete
wasser überflutete die täler und
verwüstete die felder der bauern um das
problem zu lösen wechselte man in
kalifornien zum ausbaggern bei dem das
erdreich unter wasser angesaugt und
durch ein ziel getrieben wurde um das
gold abzuscheiden der goldabbau ist in
den letzten 50 jahren viel schwieriger
geworden nicht nur die suche nach
vorkommen auch soziale politische und
umweltfaktoren bestimmen den heutigen
apa wie hat das die suche nach vorkommen
verwandelt welche risiken kamen hinzu
da wir jetzt immer tiefer und tiefer in
der erde schürfen wird die suche viele
komplexe ebenso die metallurgie des
abbaus selbst jetzt müssen wir auch noch
soziale und umweltfaktoren bewältigen
die kosten für die suche sind also
exponentiell gestiegen ebenso wie auch
die schwierigkeit neue vorkommen zu
finden
in den 1980 er jahren entwickelte man in
nevada die technologie für die
haufenlaugung
die minderwertiges oxidiertes erz
verwertete das gold kam in eisen piraten
und rostet es verrostete dabei nur der
pyrit und das gold wurde freigesetzt
dann gab man eine zyanid lösung darauf
welche das gold abschied so dass man es
sammeln konnte das war eine revolution
damit sind wir jetzt fertig die
vorkommen dafür sind aufgebraucht die
nächste revolution der goldsucher war
der fall des eisernen vorhangs nach dem
geologen praktisch auf der ganzen welt
suchen konnten
man konnte an orte gehen an denen es
aufschlüsse gab die noch niemand zuvor
entdeckt hatte dann kamen
satellitenaufnahmen verschiedene metalle
und konsorten zeigten verschiedene
spektralfarben diese konnte man sehen
und analysieren um abweichungen zu
finden die man dann direkt aussuchen
konnte das war die revolution der 1990
er jahre
seitdem gab es keine revolution mehr die
suche ist seitdem viel schwerer geworden
die funde ereignen sich immer tiefer und
tiefer in der erde
das ist für die suche wirklich
problematisch denn letztlich suchen wir
ab blind in wahrheit hat die technologie
der goldsucher stetig fortschritte
gemacht
traditionelle abbaumethoden und
herkömmliche gold vorkommen wie vor 200
jahren sind so schwer zu finden weil wir
sie schon gefunden und abgebaut haben
die industrie findet jedoch immer noch
genug neue vorkommen
das problem ist dass die einfach zu
erschließenden vorkommen oft in gebieten
liegen die von jenen die das geld für
den abbau haben als politisch brisante
gebiete erachtet werden
ich selbst finanziere die suche nach
gold in ländern wie dem kongo dem sudan
kirgisistan myanmar und bolivien orte an
denen man nicht unbedingt urlaub macht
war es übrigens ein fehler ist
man sagt immer galt abbau sei so riskant
weil es so schwer wäre etwas zu finden
die suche ist tatsächlich riskant nur
eine von 1000 suchen führt zur
einrichtung einer mine das risiko ist
also groß
investoren können viel geld verlieren
darum sagt man es seien sehr riskantes
geschäft wer wie ich in der branche ist
weiß aber dass das risiko erst mit der
entdeckung eines wirtschaftlichen
vorkommens beginnt was macht man wenn
man es gefunden hat man lässt gutachten
anfertigen ob man tatsächlich abbauen
kann und nicht doch sein geld
verschwendet das erfordert technisches
know how von geologen ingenieuren und
metallurgen dann braucht man ein anwalt
cor um das grundrecht zu sichern
man braucht oberflächen rechte muss die
unternehmerische
gesellschaftsverantwortung klären und
umwelt gutachten anfertigen lassen
man darf dabei keine fehler machen und
braucht die genehmigungen
die suche ist riskant und die
rentabilität ist ebenso ungewiss
der preis ist ebenfalls ein risiko die
preise von gold und silber schwanken zum
teil um 50 prozent innerhalb eines
jahres
ich habe selbst erlebt wie der goldpreis
in einem jahr von 300 auf 450 und der
silberpreis von fünf auf zehn dollar
stieg auch wenn man den genial ist
metallurgen hat kann dir immer noch
einen fehler machen wie man verwendet
eine neue methode die bei diesem
speziellen erz nicht funktioniert und
wenn man tatsächlich anfängt zu graben
alle gutachten basieren auf bohrungen
die können ein paar hundert meter
auseinander liegen oder auch nur ein
paar meter und dann gibt es
gesellschaftliche risiken
an manchen orten der welt ist der abbau
einfach nicht erwünscht
das kann indigene gründe haben aufgrund
der sozialen strukturen von urvölkern
und stämmen in gebieten in denen nie
geschafft wurde
der abbau ist dort einfach unerwünscht
das passiert in kanada brasilien afrika
auf der ganzen welt minen sind nun
einmal an fundorte gebunden ob die nun
großartig oder miserabel sind
man muss arbeiten wo es geht es ist ein
großes risiko nicht zu einem neuen
projekt komme nehme ich mir immer als
erstes einen stein tatsächlich fragt man
sich aber
wo bin ich wie ist die infrastruktur was
brauchen wir für den bau hier gibt es
eine straße gibt der strom gibt es
wasser steht auf dem vorkommen schon
eine kirche
das kostet hunderte millionen sogar
milliarden dollar darüber hinaus muss
man sich auch mit der politischen lage
befassen
dieses jahr wurden in guatemala tansania
den philippinen und indonesien steuern
auf minen und derartige projekte erhoben
egal ob sie sich noch im bau befinden
oder schon betrieben werden
das muss man alles beachten und dann
muss man für sein unternehmen
voraussehen wie der preis für gold oder
kupfer in zehn jahren sein wird wenn der
betrieb läuft die risiken der suche und
einrichtung einer goldmine sind nur der
anfang
das risiko in aufstrebende
bergbauunternehmen zu investieren ist
ebenso groß wie das der männer und
frauen die die erdkruste nach
schürfstellen durch kennen
bergbauunternehmen müssen die kosten
ihres know-hows und den zukünftigen wert
des abgebauten metalls voraussagen
investoren müssen nicht nur das beachten
sondern auch sorgsam abwägen und
vorhersagen ob die unternehmensleitung
den schwierigen part von der entdeckung
bis zur produktion bewältigen kann
die erfolgschancen sind erschreckend
gering und vorkommen zu finden wird
immer schwieriger wenn ich in neue
explorations unternehmen investiere ist
es meine erste aufgabe schnellstens ihre
achillesferse zu finden
vor einigen jahren ergab eine studie von
newmont dass nur eine von 1000 stellen
zu einer mine wurde und sich nur eine
von 10.000 als eine tier 1 ablagerung
erwies klingt schon sehr nach schlechten
chancen aber das täuscht denn der größte
mist ist schnell ausgeschlossen
die chancen sind immer noch nicht gut
denn die goldindustrie als ganzes
produziert jährlich etwa 90 millionen
unzen 90 millionen unzen haben wir aber
seit 2006 nicht mehr gefunden
aktuell finden wir etwa 20 millionen
unzen im jahr
wir haben da also ein echtes defizit
sieht man sich die aktuelle produktion
anfällt sie nach zwei drei vier fünf
jahren ab man darf aber nicht vergessen
dass es zehn bis zwanzig jahre dauert
ein großes vorkommen aufzubohren zu
erforschen und die mine zu errichten
was wir also heute finden wird daher
erst in frühestens zehn jahren in die
produktion gehen
das ist unbezifferte optional i tät die
welle an wörtern und übernahmen ist
unausweichlich denn die größten firmen
erschöpfen ihre vorkommen in windeseile
müssen also irgendwann die gleiche art
firmen aufkaufen wie wir
man kauft immer einen fond oder index
man kauft keine einzelnen aktien
das risiko rendite verhältnis ist da
fürchterlich dass folgt keiner logik ein
index minimiert das verlustrisiko watt
aber 75 bis 80 prozent des
gewinnpotenzials das ist das eine
zum anderen muss man die motivation
verstehen in der erkundungsphase kann
man sein geld für
zehnfach wenn jemand etwas ausgräbt das
viel größer ist als erwartet schön und
gut aber für mich für mich geht es um
die gewinnmargen der schiff unternehmen
wie ein klumpen gelbes metall über 1000
dollar kosten kann ist vielen ein rätsel
sieht man sich jedoch die kosten der
exploration und die arbeits und
energiekosten des abbaus an von steuern
und reglementierungen ganz zu schweigen
ist der wert des goldes viel einfacher
zu verstehen
[Musik]
irgendwann kommt jedes vorkommen an
einem punkt an dem sich der abbau nicht
mehr lohnt die entscheidungen die dann
getroffen werden müssen haben
weitreichende konsequenzen man sagten
ihnen sind schwer totzukriegen
sie sind wirklich schwierig totzukriegen
selbst eine mini die verlust macht was
ein wirtschaftlicher grund für die
schließung ist ist schwer totzukriegen
sie hat sagen wir mal 1000 arbeiter
deren einkommen von der mine abhängt bei
einem untertagebau muss waren große
instandhaltungskosten tragen um den
betrieb aufrecht zu erhalten
schließt man sie muss man sie konstant
auspumpen die ganze zeit wird strom
gebraucht die ausrüstung muss instand
gehalten werden ein tagebau es günstiger
fordert aber immer noch bewachung und
instandhaltung
die kosten dafür sind oft viel größer
als die mine zeitweise mit einem defizit
zu betreiben ihnen sind schwer tot zu
kriegen sie zu schließen dauert lang und
die meisten firmen nehmen lange zeit
verluste auf sich bevor sie einsehen
dass es aussichtslos ist schärfer sind
generell sehr optimistisch geborene
optimisten sonst wäre das die falsche
branche
auch wenn jeder goldsucher ein optimist
ist hat dieser optimismus und die
bereitschaft sich auf der suche nach
reichtum in gefahr zu begeben auch
schattenseiten
ich hatte zerebrale malaria toxoplasmose
und parasiten die mich fast umgebracht
hätten
ich war in abgestürzten hubschrauber und
flugzeugen musste dabei durch das
fenster fliehen
ich bin in schluchten gefallen und den
aufständen geraten was mich in liberia
fast das leben gekostet hätte und ich
weiß nicht wie oft ich in bolivien
tränengas abbekommen habe das wahre
blutbad der explorations industrie
findet aber in autos statt
schlechte straßen an schlechten orten
und die leute geraten in unfälle um die
geologen zu erzählen die ich in meiner
firma kannte die bei autounfällen
umkamen brauche ich zwei hände
das sind viele drei aus meinem jahrgang
wurden in risikogebieten erschossen zwei
beim aussteigen aus einem hubschrauber
in ländern auf den philippinen
einer wurde in südamerika von sagen wir
mal üblen kerlen erschossen
es ist ein gefährliches geschäft aber
ich liebe es und trotzdem risiko für
mich funktioniert dass ich lebe noch
so ist das normal
die herausforderungen bei der suche nach
diesem seltsamen gelben metall wachsen
jedes jahr aufgrund der entwicklungen
des letzten halben jahrhunderts fällt
ihre bewältigung den ceos der chef
unternehmen zusehends schwerer im
bergbau gewerbe zu arbeiten weil die
letzten 30 jahre wirklich schwer
außerdem ist das ansehen und der respekt
für die arbeit im bergbau noch geringer
als bei der müllabfuhr
warum suchen sich viele kompetente leute
lieber andere karriere felder als den
bergbau wie die führungskräfte von
bergbauunternehmen sind größtenteils aus
meiner generation
und sie sind also alt wir haben
erfahrung aber langsam geht uns die
puste aus das größte problem heutige ceo
von bergbaufirmen ist dass keiner den
ich getroffen habe und das sind viele
verstanden hat was gold ist sie bauen es
ab wie kupfer zinn oder irgendetwas
anderes
aber man sollte es ganz anders abbauen
es hat eine ganz andere dynamik dass
doktor flow verhältnis ist anders da man
gold hortet und nicht verbraucht vor den
1970 er jahren verstand man gold und das
ziel war die goldmine so lange wie
möglich zu betreiben
wie gesagt heutzutage versteht dass
keiner der ceos mehr die ich getroffen
habe
ihnen wurde beigebracht es wäre eine
generische handelsware
das ist es aber nicht und darum
verwendet die gesamte industrie um den
goldabbau ihr kapital völlig falsch ein
gramm pro tonne entspricht einem anteil
von eins zu einer million
von einer million sandkörnern wäre also
eines aus gold das ist nicht viel bei
leibe nicht aber man kann damit geld
verdienen das ist unsere größenordnung
die schwierigkeiten dabei sind
unbegreiflich wir bohren schließlich 300
meter tief in der hoffnung einen flößt
zu finden
der vielleicht 100 oder 200 meter breit
ist die größenordnung
das bohrloch ist so groß dass wird
halbiert die eine hälfte wird gemahlen
und 30 gramm als probe entnommen
diese 30 gramm probe repräsentiert an
einen würfel 25 auf 25 auf 25 das
illustriert die komplexität unserer
probleme als ich meine erste goldmine
fand was ich vorher schon öfter
fälschlicherweise gedacht hatte als ich
es zum ersten mal wirklich schaffte
arbeitete ich in honduras bezahlt von
einem australier mit einer idee dass
diese heißen quellen gold ablagerungen
sein könnten
ich besorgte mir geologische karten
welche dürftig ausfallen
damals bekamen karten in honduras nur
von der regierung und die hat er
verschiedene bereiche ausgeschnitten
es war also schwierig auf der karte sah
ich lad embla derer eine brodelnd heiße
quelle
ich fand dort einen großen verkieselten
sind auf schloss typisch für heiße
quellen
da war nichts zu holen er enthielt kaum
geld direkt daneben fand ich in einer
anderen eigentlich uninteressanten fels
orte ordentliche mengen sie die macht
gramm gold es ist detektivarbeit
man versucht sich zu erschließen was an
dieser stelle vor einer 10 oder 100
millionen jahren passiert war
anhand minimaler taten das
herauszufinden faszinierte mich schon
immer wenn es klappt wird es sich
unglaublich an
ich habe es geschafft es funktioniert
das passiert nicht oft aber als geologe
liebe ich es egal wo ich hingehe sehe
ich mir steine an und denke über sie
nach das gefällt mir
gold ist einzigartig da es anders als
beispielsweise silber nicht verbraucht
wird
der hohe wert macht es wirtschaftlich
auch kleine mengen zb in elektroartikeln
zurückzugewinnen
dadurch verbleibt jede geförderte unze
an der oberfläche
gold wird nicht verbraucht alle sie
abgebaute gold es noch an der oberfläche
es mag in pyramiden vergraben sein aber
es ist verfügbar und für den richtigen
preis kommt es wieder auf den markt
das bedeutet der goldabbau vergrößert
den bereits jetzt gewaltigen gold vorrat
immer weiter der goldabbau ist also
anders als die gewinnung von öl kupfer
oder eisen da diese rohstoffe bald nach
der förderung wieder verbraucht werden
anders als gold die goldförderung ist in
den letzten 150 jahren dank neuer
technologien und vorkommen erheblich
gestiegen aber die zuwachsrate der
überirdischen vorräte ist ziemlich
stabil zwischen ein und drei prozent
verblieben
aktuell wäre die beste schätzung wohl
dass es 100 87.000 tonnen gold gibt so
das ist alles gold das je abgebaut wurde
das ist der bestand man könnte auch
inventar sagen
und dann gibt es den zuwachs
dieser beträgt aktuell gemessen an 2016
etwa 3200 tonnen
wir haben also 187.000 tonnen bestand
und 3200 tonnen zuwachs wenn man das
teilt kommt dabei 58,8 heraus das ist
das torverhältnis liefe die produktion
mit der gleichen geschwindigkeit weiter
würde sich der goldbestand von aktuell
100 87.000 tonnen in 58 jahren
verdoppeln das heißt aber auch dass die
jährliche gold inflation 1,7 prozent
beträgt was eher niedrig ist
interessanterweise wächst die
weltbevölkerung auch jährlich um etwa
1,7 prozent
wenn es um geld geht sind vertrauen und
stabilität am wichtigsten
vergleicht man das mit der inflation des
fiat geld ist das geldvolumen seit 1971
jährlich um durchschnittlich neun
prozent gewachsen
seit 1913 waren es acht prozent pro jahr
also jetzt deutlich mehr käme es bei
kupfer oder schlimmer noch bei öl zu
lieferstörungen wenn zb die straße von
hormus blockiert würde würden die
ölvorräte nach wenigen monaten versiegen
und der ölpreis wäre stark betroffen
bei gold hingegen hätte ein großer
streik in afrika der die fördermenge um
zehn prozent verringert keine
auswirkungen auf den goldpreis
daher der bestand des bereits
geförderten goldes existiert man handelt
dann das bestehende gold wenn der preis
stimmt wird auch jeder goldbesitzer zum
verkäufer das ist ja gerade das schöne
daran
darum ist meiner meinung nach gold so
kapitalstark weltweit kommen 20 prozent
aller gold produkte aus einer einzigen
raffinerie in der schweiz im letzten
abschnitt unserer reise sehen wir uns
diesen faszinierenden vorgang aus der
nähe an und ergründen wie kleine goldene
einschlüsse im geförderten gestein zu
goldbarren werden
wir verwenden hier tatsächlich sehr sehr
alte techniken
es wurde nichts radikal neues erfunden
alle technologien die wir hier nutzen
existieren seit hunderten wenn nicht
sogar tausenden von jahren
natürlich würde alles verfeinert
wir betreten jetzt die sogenannte
schwarze gießerei schwarz weil das
material hier immer noch
verunreinigungen enthält es ist vor
allem die direkt aus der mine ein doré
barren besteht aus gold silber und
verunreinigungen wir reden sogar schon
von tory wenn es erst ein oder zwei
prozent gold enthält und sonst
größtenteils aus silber besteht das ist
hochwertige story diese bohrlöcher hier
wurden in der mine gemacht damit die
hersteller wissen was sie und schicken
die bahn landen in unserer raffinerie
zusammen mit altgold schmuck und gold
resten aus der industrie die raffinieren
es bis es eine hohe reinheit von 99,99
prozent reinem gold erreicht das ist
unsere standardprozedur um den schmelz
vorgang zu beschleunigen
wir erreichen 250 grad und können in 45
minuten ließen
[Musik]
wir entnehmen unsere proben immer dem
flüssigen gold nur so können wir sicher
gehen dass die probe repräsentativ ist
[Musik]
die bohrung dieser probe ist dann
repräsentativ für die gesamte schmelzen
eine probe landet in unserem labor ein
im labor des kunden und eine weitere
bleibt für streitfälle in reserve
das hier ist die elektrolyse raffinerie
das sind die anoden die wir gerade
gemacht haben
die anoden kommen dann in unsere
elektrolyse anlagen die elektrolyse
anlagen sind mit säure gefüllte und
stehen unter strom
das löst alles auf
sind stromstärke und spannung aber
richtig eingestellt können wir
sicherstellen dass sich all das reine
gold an die kathoden heftet das ist das
ergebnis der elektrolyse reines gold
das ist reines gold ganz genau
wenn es auf der raffinerie kommt müssen
wir es für die verarbeitung zu barren
vorbereiten
wir haben zwei schmelztiegel einer wird
gerade erhitzt der andere wird gegossen
hier erstarrt er dann langsam
wir schneiden es dann den solche quader
dieser hier wiegt etwas weniger als ein
kilogramm
kino
jetzt kommen wir in die weiße gießerei
weiß weil hier nur reines hochwertiges
feingold verarbeitet wird
die blöcke werden auf dieses um laufband
geladen ein roboter nimmt den block und
fügt ein kleines stück hinzu
mehr
[Applaus]
dann nimmt ein arbeiter den block der
knapp ein kilogramm wiegt und etwas gold
trat und schmilzt beides ein
hier sieht man die flamme wenn es
erstarrt wird der sauerstoff
herausgebracht
es kühlt ab kommt ins wasser
und am ende hat man einen fertigen
glänzendem gold bahn auf der anderen
seite sehen wir 100 gramm barren 100
gramm barren werden autonom von robotern
hergestellt die blöcke von vorhin waren
ja für kilogramm bahn
diese sind 400 gramm barren also knapp
unter 100 gramm
der roboter nimmt ihn und legt ihn auf
die waage dann fügt er etwas draht hinzu
wenn man da hinten genau hinsieht ist
der ofen selbst ein tunnel sich der blog
landet mit etwas draht also auf dem
förderband und das förderband fährt
durch diesen tunnel heraus kommt am ende
der eingeschmolzen bahn von denen machen
wir etwa 1000 am tag tausenden tag
das hier ist der letzte schritt in der
herstellung der goldbarren die
qualitätsprüfung
hier wird also von hand das gewicht
jedes einzelnen barrens überprüft wenn
man genau sein will geht es nicht anders
sie nimmt jeden einzelnen waren legt ihn
auf die waage und überprüft das gewicht
letztlich ist diese dame der wichtigste
teil da sie die waren überprüft sie ist
die letzte person vor dem kunden die
dehnbaren in der hand hat im geschäft
der raffinierung gibt es zwei große
herausforderungen
das eine ist genauigkeit man muss sehr
präzise arbeiten
zum anderen muss man schnell sein da man
es sich aufgrund des wertes des goldes
etwa 40.000 dollar pro kilo nicht
leisten kann das metall einfach
herumliegen zu haben
die ganze produktion ist also
genauestens durchgeplant
alle schritte sind auf die minute genau
getaktet
die arbeiten sind perfekt orchestriert
damit dass ankommende metall den prozess
so schnell wie möglich durch laufen kann
der prozess der goldsucher des abbaus
und der raffinierung gibt dem gold nicht
nur seinen glanz sondern auch seinen
wirtschaftlichen wert da fiat währungen
heute keinerlei finanzielle verankerung
mehr haben ist gold heute wohl mehr wert
denn je gold hat etwas magisches und
silber ebenso das gewicht die haptik die
wärme die farbe es ist wunderschön und
das war schon immer es ist klar das
herzstück der letzten jahrhunderte wenn
nicht sogar jahrtausende unserer
geschichte es verändert das leben der
menschen
gold ist mehr als nur ein glänzendes
ding kalt ist etwas besonderes
wir verstehen nun also besser warum gold
geld ist warum wir allen alternativen
die die menschheit der sand zum trotz
immer wieder zu diesem gelben metall
zurückkehren
wir haben uns angesehen welche
widrigkeiten goldschürfer auf der suche
nach neuen vorkommen bewältigen müssen
wir haben den pfad des goldes vom
funkeln in den augen des geologen zum
fertigen allseits bekannten barren
verfolgt gold zu finden wird immer
schwieriger
der abbau immer teurer die
herausforderungen für diejenigen die ihr
leben lang nach diesem edelsten aller
metalle suchen wachsen stetig seit
seiner entdeckung genieß gold bei der
menschheit einen besonderen stellenwert
jahrtausendelang wurde stabilität und
eine möglichkeit über generationen
wohlstand zu messen zu bewahren und zu
beschützen
es bleibt die einzige universell
anerkannte währung und der einzige
wertspeicher den regierungen nicht
entwerten können
in der nächsten folge betrachten wir
verschiedene einstellungen gegenüber
gold im westen und im osten und erklären
den unterschied zwischen den goldpreis
und den preis des goldes
wir betrachten die gold gehandelt wird
ob der goldpreis manipuliert wurde und
wenn dem so ist von wem
zuletzt beleuchten wir legenden und
verschwörungstheorien rund um das
älteste geld der welt seien sie auch
nächstes mal mit dabei
[Musik]